welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it's ice to see
you back on the channel since our last
Batman video we've had a ton of new
information come out on the film and
throughout this video we'll be going
through everything you need to know
about the movie we'll be covering a
teaser on what the penguin could look
like Robert Pattinson straining and a
new interview with zoe kravitz as well
as matt reeves there's a lot of cool
little details with any story that
really point out how the overall film
maybe and they've definitely got me
excited for what's in store now there
may be some spoilers here so if you want
to go into the movie as blind as
possible then I highly recommend that
you turn off now make sure you subscribe
to the channel to never miss an update
and without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into our
breakdown of the Batman
okay so firstly we're gonna be starting
off with the Matt Reeves interview that
was dropped on The Daily Beast last week
in it Reeves was asked several questions
about the process of the film how it
felt to be dealing with the delays and
the ins and outs of his series tales
from the loop I'll leave it linked in
the description below if you want to
check it out but the most interesting
aspect of the entire talk is how Reeves
is differentiating his Batman from the
other depictions that we've seen of the
character on screen when discussing how
his Batman would be Matt said the
following the way I loved Apes is the
way that I love Batman the only two
franchises that might have been
something I would have connected with
amazingly are the ones I was approached
by that's a very special thing I can't
say that about almost any other
franchise that they would have been the
right fit for me my thing about it on
both of them is that I had a particular
tag that for me was personal I feel like
if I can't approach something through
perspective that resonates with me on
some personal level I don't know where
to put the camera and I don't know how
to talk to the actors I appreciate that
you want me to do a Batman movie but I
just don't want to do a Batman movie I
want to do a Batman movie that has a
chance to be something different and
humanist it's the same reason I did the
Apes movies those movies were incredibly
personal to me despite the fact that
they were what they were so I made a
pitch for what it would be and to my
great pleasure it turned out that they
were totally open to that
I took a tremendously long time working
with my partners on that script and they
waited and when I turned it in they
wanted to make it I've been so
incredibly fortunate that they've been
so open to it being different and one of
the exciting things about it is that it
drew an incredibly interesting and
talented number of actors who wanted to
be involved in it to me that's the dream
now when this interview first dropped a
lot of people interpreted it as meaning
that the film would be woke there were
cries of it being sjw bullcrap and that
it would be in line with the recent
trend of movies by Hollywood that puts
politics before plot however when
reading this and knowing what we know
about the movie I disagree heavily with
that interpretation we already know that
the film will be a detective story that
centers around Batman investigating a
string of murders in Gotham
last month we dropped a report that
discussed how insiders informed us that
the work would be in line with Batman
earth one and I think this hints at the
humanist side that Matt is talking about
in that Bruce really has to deal with
the pressure of donning a mantle and
what his mission to save Gotham
ultimately leads to it's a far more
grounded tale and the majority of Batman
films and Bruce really feels like he's
the underdog throughout it fighting
against a corrupt system that caused the
death of his parents add to this the
fact that it too contains several
murders and we may have to watch the
psychological toll that is takes on
Bruce and Batman films there are often
killings but it's rare that we see Bruce
truly horrified by them and as of now we
haven't really seen him deal with the
psychological toll that this takes often
in murder mysteries and dramas we see
the damage that murders can do to the
mind of someone trying to understand
them and I take Matt's interview at
hinting at the toll that it will take on
Bruce Batman often tries to paint
himself out as a symbol but at the core
of it he's a man that ultimately ends up
isolating himself from even his family
because of what he's had to go through
through the years whilst I loved the bat
God style Batman that we've gotten
things like BBS I would also love to see
more of the air one style storyline that
deals with Bruce realizing he may be out
of his depth and ultimately succumbing
to
Batman is often depicted as a
muscle-bound man that looks a bit like
definition in the mirror
however they are definitely doing
something different with him and that
leads us to our next point that is
Robert Pattinson slook the actor was
recently seen jogging and working out
make sure you stretch Rob don't want you
pulling a Sam hamstring hair get it cuz
some ham wrote the script about my neck
you know in any way highbrow jokes here
at the channel now as you can expect
plenty of people on Twitter who also
happened to probably be personal
trainers as well as experts in biology
and fitness they didn't like it and then
we got people who did and the usual back
and forth happened where people said it
wasn't their Batman and yada yada yada
anyway personally I think that him being
skinny at this point makes a lot of
sense and though I can't understand
people wanting a bulkier Batman if we
look at the comics Robb is more in line
with the earliest stories than a lot of
the bigger depictions so firstly we do
know that this is a year two story
Batman has recently come back off
spending 7 years around the world in
which he learnt martial arts forensic
science chemistry and so on so he hasn't
really had that much time to hit the gym
because he was mainly focused on
training his mind in his body this is
reflected in the comics in year 1 and
the aforementioned earth one in which he
is still muscular but Lena rather than
bulky what tends to happen in the comics
that tell his origin story is that he
comes back to Gotham having learnt all
this stuff and then he starts properly
training over the years he's already
gained the knowledge that he needs to
know so he doesn't need to focus on
learning as much and therefore he can
take on perfecting his body putting on
muscle mass takes years and years and at
the age of 25 which is when Bruce
typically returns to Gotham he tends to
bulk up till he's about 30 and then
stays at this weight for the next 10
years or more so I do think this makes a
lot of sense and again
this hammer sound the fact that this is
a different kind of Batman to what we've
seen before he's more of a detective and
the guy isn't fighting Superman he's
fighting criminals and back alleys so
the idea of being bigger isn't necessary
yet that's kinda how those two points
are tied together but it also seems that
we're getting something more in
with what we'd expect to see in terms of
the penguin before we get into that
though I just wanna let you know we're
giving away five free copies of the new
Black Widow book by serial box it comes
as either an e-book or audio book and
cereal box was kind enough to put the
cover artwork in the description in case
you want a cool desktop background all
you have to do to be on with a chance of
winning the books themselves I'll like
the video subscribe to the channel and
comment on the updates below I'll
announce the winners in the pin comment
tomorrow so make sure you check back on
the video to see if you got the prize
the competition is just running for 24
hours so make sure you quick and best of
luck to everyone who takes part
okay so here's Rob McClure talking about
him coming across the prosthetics for
penguin whilst working on the mrs.
Doubtfire musical though when I went
into the place to get to get with the
process you just saw I walked in and
they were they were like oh hang on love
witches we just have to clear off this
table and they were building the penguin
prosthetics for Colin Farrell in the new
Batman movie and I was like oh I'm in
the right place I mean so not a massive
amount of things that we can take from
that however we do now know for definite
that Colin Farrell will be getting
things added to his face in order to
complete his penguin look Ferrell has
stated that he's putting on more weight
for the part and this adds to the idea
that he will be taking on the classic
appearance of the character I don't
think these prosthetics will be full-on
as I think from what we've seen that
that may be a bit jarring Batman is
filming on the streets of learning and
Glasgow rather than all being green
screen and looking at the Batmobile and
Batsuit they seem quite toned down and
very DIY this grounds the movie a lot so
a doubt that it will be a long Pinocchio
nose but I could be lying hey I think it
will likely be something like what they
did to Charlize Theron on bombshell
where they just changed the characters
features but it still looked like a real
person obviously time will tell but
that's just what I would take from this
judging by the other elements of the
movie that we've seen so far and finally
we have an interview with Zoe Kravitz
that talks about her role as Catwoman
this was originally posted by Vanity
Fair but
paywall a lot of their articles and had
already clicked at one so for some
reason I couldn't open it again so thank
you to Batman Twitter account the bat
source for pulling together the main
segments of interest for us so he was
asked how preparing for the role was
going in quarantine and she said the
following in regards to her die in
exercise yes I mean it's not like the
studio called and said don't get fat
[ __ ] but I had been training now for
maybe four or five months and the first
couple of weeks that I self quarantined
I remember texting the director a texted
mat and I was like we might have to make
the catsuit a few sizes bigger when this
is over so I quickly decided to get my
ish together and I've been working out
virtually with my trainer David Higgins
five days a week and it's actually been
really great because it's been giving me
some kind of structure because I do it
at the same time and it also makes the
weekends feel like a weekend because I
don't work out on the weekends and it
just gives me just oh it's different
it's a different kind of day so it's
actually been really great just for my
mental health and kind of foods kind of
the only thing that I have food and wine
and bringing me joy right now so I'm
definitely eating whatever the F I want
but yeah I try to stay in decent shape
so I don't have to start from scratch so
what we can take from that is that
cravat will be wearing a cat suit for
the film and that she's on the old
definition diet hashtag sun's out guns
out there were worries that you wouldn't
actually be appearing in a suit in the
film due to the bike chase scene which
we saw filming in Glasgow that had her
just wearing a typical biker outfit but
this confirms that there will indeed be
a cat suit every buff anne's wet dream
just come true when we will get a chance
to see it we don't know yeah but it does
at the very least let us know that there
will be costumes galore throughout the
movie as always I'm very hyped for the
film and hopefully it isn't too long
before we get to see some first looks
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on these updates and what you
want to see in the next couple of weeks
I'm gonna be keeping my eye close to the
big news and you'll be the first to hear
oh if anything major drops make sure you
stay locked to the channel and please
give us a thumbs up if you enjoyed the
video
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the insane details that we
notice in Avengers end game after binge
watching MCU it's got a lot of cool at
least our eggs so definitely check it
out after this you want to support the
child from his letters 99 cents a month
then please click the join button below
you access to content early and can also
suggest video topics and breakdowns we
massively appreciate it and it goes a
long way to helping videos like this get
made you wanna come chat to us after the
show either follow us at definition
whitey or click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace